this is our hand pick guide for your
weekend and first up
i've got a must listen for you it's the
raising good humans podcast
with dr eliza pressman parents trust me
you don't want to miss this dr eliza is
actually going to be on this show very
soon and i can't wait she's a
developmental psychologist and a mom of
two and her podcast tackles
everything she talks to parents experts
authors
there are so many takeaways and
she's a friend of mine and someone i've
been lucky enough to work with since my
first daughter olive was born
eight years ago she's changed my life
and today's episode
is all about highly sensitive children
and that's kids who are extremely
sensitive to their environment
dr lisa is going to dig into that and
share some specific tips for parents
this made me think about my daughter
frankie when she shows up in her
nightgown
somewhere out in the world and i'm like
you weren't at our house
for the last hour as she cried and said
this is the only fabric
that can touch her skin it's like things
are very real for kids
and there's you know a lot of things us
parents can
bond on and learn from so check it out
okay
next up photographer kiel james patrick
instagram kjp for all the cozy halloween
inspo you could ever want look at these
pics
kjp is a new england-based fashion
designer with about a million followers
he ties his photos to the season so his
whole page is full of amber and orange
and americana
you can practically smell the pumpkin
spice latte
through your phone screens i love it
okay
next is a pick to read and
to cook it's lasagna by anna hezel
anna is an editor at taste and a food
journalist
who's written deep dive pieces on tuna
melts
ginger gum and the history of drinking
raw eggs
in lasagna she takes an in-depth look at
the dish and serves up recipes and
mouth-watering photos of
every variety of lasagna you could
ever want from the classics to the
evolution
of what's current at the moment anyway
this
book rules it's also recommended by the
creator of garfield
that guy loves lasagna
it's time for the little yellow book
yay i love the little yellow book i work
really hard on it it's a list of
personal picks updated every week on our
site and it's all the things that i
absolutely love
and i'm just dying to share with you so
like
beekeepers natural products this is
actually a throat spray
and i use it all the time for the show
because sometimes i actually do lose my
voice from talking so much
so instead of telling me to shut up i
just
use some of this and then keep on
chatting so
they also have it for kids too and by
the way lily collins cameron diaz
they're all investors in this
so this is a another cult classic
okay for even more of the picks check
out drew's little yellow book
on the website now and that was our
[Music]
weekender